ce dimanche ammann n'a en apparence rien
perdu de la tranquillité qui la
caractérise les habitants se préparent à
dix jours du début du mois de ramadan
difficile de deviner que le pouvoir
royal vient pourtant de subir une
secousse politique à laquelle il n'est
pas habitué samedi une quinzaine de
personnalités proches du pouvoir ont été
arrêtés dont le prince hamza demi-frère
du roi abdallah ii lors d'une conférence
de presse le vice premier ministre
jordanien les a accusés d'avoir porté
atteinte à la stabilité et à la sécurité
du royaume
les premiers éléments de l'enquète
montre que des personnes de l'entourage
du prince hamza transmettent des
allégations et des courriers à des
parties étrangères y compris à la soi
disant opposition en exil afin qu'elle
les utilise pour inciter à agir contre
la sécurité intérieure et à déformer les
faits âgé de 41 ans hamza et le dernier
fils du roi hussein fruit d'un quatrième
mariage avec la reine nour américaine de
naissance il avait été nommé prince
héritier lorsque abdallah ii a accédé au
trône jordanie en 1999
mais en 2004 ce dernier lui a retiré son
titre pour l'attribuer à son fils aîné
dans une vidéo filmées avec son
téléphone portable demi frère du roi
indique avoir été assigné à résidence et
nie toute tentative de déstabilisation
du pouvoir
il affirme qu'il n'obéira pas aux ordres
de ne pas sortir ou à communiquer comme
je le dis aux chefs de cabinet quand il
est venu me voir je ne suis pas la
personne responsable de l'échec de la
gouvernance de la corruption et de la
compétence qui se sont répandus dans
notre structure de gouvernement durant
les quinze à vingt dernières années qui
n'ont fait qu'empirer depuis je ne suis
pas responsable du manque de confiance
de la population dans leurs institutions
ce sont eux les responsables
cette série d'arrestations survient
alors que le royaume de jordanie doit
célébrer son centième anniversaire le 11
avril prochain pour le pouvoir royal
issu de la dynastie hachémite l'enjeu
est de taille alors que le pays apparaît
comme l'un des plus stables du
moyen-orient officiellement en paix avec
israël depuis 1994 la jordanie est un
pilier de la sécurité régionale pour les
américains et leurs alliés
le pays accueille également un million
trois cent mille réfugiés syriens et
près de 2 millions de réfugiés
palestiniens selon l'onu la stabilité de
la jordanie est également une priorité
pour les monarchies du golfe l'arabie
saoudite les émirats arabes unis et le
qatar ont ainsi apporté leur soutien au
roi dallas 2